now that's just one big plate that the
nfl is spinning as the season approaches
the other big plate relates to the
coronavirus pandemic which
if you're paying any attention
whatsoever is not subsiding people don't
seem to care like they used to some
never did a hundred and eighteen
thousand are now dead they're projecting
200 000 by later this year and the
numbers are going up in various cities
and states throughout the country some
states and cities that have tried to
reopen are having to pull back and
you've got crisis situations in some
places and we've got positive tests of
players in the nfl and they're not even
together they're not even under the roof
of their facilities yet roger goodell
acknowledged the greenberg last night
that positive covet 19 tests will happen
and word came out yesterday that several
members now the report from nfl media
was several members of the texans and
the cowboys tested positive i'm told it
was two cowboys two texans so it's not
as dire as maybe it initially seemed
total of four between two franchises one
is ezekiel elliot chris but but look
this not a surprise with that many
players in the nfl spread out across the
country yeah guys are going to test
positive it's going to happen it's not a
surprise that four players that we know
of are positive and there's probably
more out there i mean we already know
about von miller for example but there's
other players out there i assume that
have tested positive that we don't know
about
yeah well i i would think so you know
honestly i'm shocked we haven't heard
more about it really i i am i you know
and again uh it's surprising that
honestly ezekiel elliott his camp and
everybody else kept it so quiet you know
i thought we would have heard about it
by now but i mean yeah this is the
reality of the situation i mean you have
four guys out of 180 well what do we
think is gonna happen when we get
together and you know everybody starts
you know
practicing against you
against each other sweating i that this
is where
you know again i just don't know where
the nfl and the players stand with this
whole agreement yet i'm a little
concerned about it but yes this is a
microcosm of what's going on in society
and of course yeah i think texas is one
of those states right now we're seeing
some rising numbers but it's not going
away it's here to stay for the time
being it doesn't sound like we're
getting a vaccine anytime soon yes we're
going to have testing you know but we're
seeing numbers go up and if you listen
to any expert out there and it's purely
the science of it they're telling you
this is not a second wave we're still
dealing with the first wave so what
happens when you know that so-called
second wave that they predict to be
coming happens and
what weather starts to get colder up
here in the northeast in late october
early november you know i'm just afraid
it's going to wipe out full teams and
it's going to wipe out weeks of the
season and i just you know i'm again i'm
very interested to see how this plays
out what kind of agreement the nflpa can
get with the nfl
yesterday we also got a glimpse of the
transparency or lack thereof that nfl
franchises will be applying to
situations where players test positive
for the corona virus with
any other
illness or injury we are accustomed to
transparency via the injury reports now
this time of year there's no obligation
for the teams to say anything whatsoever
about player health but the statement
from the cowboys gives us an idea of
maybe how teams will try to deal with it
maybe they'll just call it illness and
won't elaborate maybe they won't go into
any details whatsoever here's the
statement from the cowboys dude a
federal and local privacy laws we are
unable to provide information regarding
the personal health of any of our
employees we are following all cdc local
and nfl guidelines to keep our
facilities safe including limited
employee access look i i don't want to
get into the whole who does hipaa apply
to and who doesn't it apply to it it's
it was created to restrict what health
care
facilities and health care workers can
say about someone's health condition it
doesn't apply to the general public it
doesn't technically apply to the cowboys
and it gets violated if it does apply
all the time with the injury report so
this is just kind of i think a way for
the cowboys to turn the page on this for
now and again there's no obligation to
say anything for now they could just say
we have no obligation in the offseason
to say anything about the health of any
of our players and
they won't even say how many without
naming names you would like to think
they would say how many and there is a
public health component to all of this i
don't know why people they're right
that's why about covert 19. it's not
it's not like you have aids or herpes or
some other disease that is if it is
scandalous or embarrassing and weird
yeah
yeah right i mean and again i just threw
out a couple there there were plenty of
that people would say oh i don't want
anyone to know i have that and that's a
personal choice but this is yeah we've
been hearing all along it's the flu it's
the flu it's the flu it's not but when
it comes to the stigma attached to it
it's the flu i got sick
an invisible virus made its way into my
system as i was out and about now maybe
there's some embarrassment that people
are putting themselves in positions to
catch it because we should know better
than to compromise our own health and
compromise the health of others by
catching it but there's no stigma in
having it
i i think that's the first thing that
jumped out to me mike is i was a little
surprised by ezekiel elliott's reaction
you know i you know i don't know just i
would think a lot of players would take
the von miller
approach i think i would have as well
like hey i have the sickness be careful
everybody out there this is what i'm
going through you know hey for me it's
not that bad so don't panic if you do
get it you might be able to be you know
you might have symptoms like me but
let's protect others out there because
their symptoms might be more serious i
was surprised by that now like was i
surprised that this medical information
got out there of course not i mean come
on the nfl yes we always hear you know
the these types of uh injuries or
surgeries or something that happens in
the offseason get out when you know like
you said in the nfl the teams have uh
they don't have to report that or
especially with drug testing and failed
drug tests that's supposed to be a
private matter that gets out every year
with almost every single player so you
know again um
the nfl is not very good at keeping
these type of secrets
i don't know how you know
this is reported
at first but ezekiel elliott's obviously
embarrassed or a little upset about it i
don't think he should be and yeah to the
bigger problem mike too i just wish
there was a little more transparency
with all teams right now to just know
how many players do you know that have
actually had it already and where are we
at as a league and players and
everything like that
uh i i hope people aren't being like
ezekiel elliott keeping it quiet and
keeping it from teams and
you know not informing us to gain more
knowledge about the situation
and you'll wonder why zeke is invoking
hipaa now again hipaa doesn't apply when
it comes to someone finding out about it
his agent confirming it etc i can't help
but wonder whether or not there's some
level of embarrassment because he was at
that party remember that part that's
what i thought too it's been a long time
a long time ago he was at that party at
dak prescott's house and hey if you
hadn't been going to a party when
everyone was on lockdown you wouldn't
have tested positive for it so i don't
think he wants to be chastised publicly
for doing something stupid that's where
i think the silence and the discretion
comes into this there's no stigma in
having it the statement is in how you
got it because you did something dumb to
get it potentially and when we saw the
videos and and we spent time on the
story of the the dinner party that dak
prescott had at the time when everyone
was on full lockdown that may be the
thing that has caused ezekiel elliott to
to to to
be a little bit concerned that it got
out and the other thing too and i don't
want to cause him to cause a problem
between zeke and his agent rocky
arsenault one of zeke's tweets yesterday
was my agent only confirmed the story
was already written reporters have been
calling my agent all morning zeke don't
you understand
that without confirmation from your
agent they weren't going to use it but
if your agent says no comment
that
i don't know that for sure they're not
going to use it but the reason they're
calling the agent for confirmation is
they they they need that peace before
they can be comfortable reporting on
something like this that may not be
correct so when the agent confirms it
that's their license to report it that's
a key piece in the thing making it into
the public domain and i again i don't
want to cause trouble between zeke and
rocky arsenal but i think you already
did that
just keep your mouth shut somebody god
you're right don't say is it true is it
true
no comment we got no comment i'm not
commenting on the health of of uh and
the and the the illness or or lack
thereof or whatever i'm just i had
nothing to say that's it
that's it yeah that's all you got to say
right make the media members call other
people to try to get confirmation not
you know get confirmation from somebody
inside your own camp you're right i
think you're right about that maybe not
go with it maybe not go with it because
they can't get your information exactly
right it would be probably hard to get
confirmation on a lot of stories this
day and age because we're not seeing
each other we're not in office buildings
we don't have the connections we usually
do all those things and to bring it back
full circle too mike i mean i know that
was something you know
i texted you yesterday when i first
heard about the ezekiel elliott
situation oh i wonder did dak get it too
because that's where i think both of our
minds went we went well what about that
dak birthday party they had so you're
probably right in your read of ezekiel
elliott probably embarrassed in the fact
that man i got caught going out when
people were supposed to be on lockdown
you know and now i got it and maybe just
doesn't want it thrown back in the space
but regardless zeke you had it and you
survived it and everything's good and
you know i think you could do a public
service by kind of informing people out
there what it was like to go through it
and how you feel and how you felt
through it uh as it as it was happening
so uh again that's what i would like to
hear more of that especially with the
nfl players we need to hear more
you know we need to have more what do i
want to say mike i don't want to say
guinea pigs but that's what i mean just
players athletes this age who have it
what are the symptoms been like has
anybody had anything serious i mean i
think that's part of the gathering of
the information here as we go forward to
see if we can really make this all work
and happen
yeah we need to get people to care about
this again it seems like people don't
care if they ever did but more and more
people just seem to act like uh it's
over it isn't over is it insane it's
insane like i grew up people telling me
about all these weird wars and
everything and people dying and how many
people died and how horrible it is and
here we are over a hundred thousand
deaths and you're right it's like ah
it's just it's become second fiddle it's
become third fiddle it's like we've just
totally forgot about it as a society and
uh i just yeah i'm with you i just i
hope everybody still realizes this is
very real and could still get very scary
and let's not like start forming mosh
pits and having concerts quite
yet and it's amazing when you see
some of the photos of the nightclubs
that are open there was the kid rock
club in nashville i think it was and how
many people were there and the knee-jerk
reaction
from the corona truthers is well nobody
said any of that when the protests were
happening well first of all
the protest is an organic reaction to a
societal injustice that has been hiding
in plain sight for years and it reached
a boiling point with george floyd and a
lot of the protesters i see are wearing
masks i didn't see a single mask in that
photo from the kid rock club the other
night so there's a lot of people
engaging in unsafe behavior getting
pressed together in confined spaces
without masks it's very different and
it's a deliberate premeditated effort to
go out and have a good time it's not
people lashing out in anger uh over
things that are happening that shouldn't
be happening there's a big difference
between protest huge differences and
let's go hang out at this club
gatherings all right so we'll see we'll
see
how will the numbers go up will they not
go up over the next few weeks one other
point to make on this before we go two
quick ones one i mentioned four players
to have tested positive two from the
cowboys two from the texans one of the
players from the texans was at george
floyd's funeral last week
so and there were like 25
players and representatives of the
texans there so
wow we're gonna wait and see whether or
not anybody else ends up testing
positive out of that event and also uh
the the plan right now for nfl players
is to be tested two or three times a
week i still and look i i know that well
it's not practical to test more often
than that i i i'm we need to get to the
point where there's a a test a reliable
easy quick safe test that involves a
swap of the mouth or a prick of the
finger and it tells you immediately
whether or not you have it and i think
the more often you're tested in that
simple easy way
the better off everyone's going to be
because i got if i got tested yesterday
i was negative and i don't get tested
today and i'm not getting tested until
tomorrow there's a chance i'm currently
positive i think if i know it today
everyone is better off chris so i hope
we can get to that point i i thought we
were gonna get to that point by august
or september and maybe we will but i'm
not real comfortable with two or three
tests a week i want to get to the point
where they can do reliable testing every
day
yeah i mean i think it's the safest way
yeah i mean there's just too much wiggle
room between you know two and three
tests a week they're just yeah
you're gonna have players you're gonna
you know the chances are with over 2 000
players and things like that
somebody's gonna come across somebody
that's you know got the virus and that
that's where it's scary and again this
is where i just i'm worried as far as i
just wish we had more fail-safe plans
right now i don't know maybe they need
to keep a 90-man roster this year in the
nfl maybe every team needs 90 players
and maybe that's the way they do it they
just got to have a bunch of players who
are like on the quarantine practice
squad and that's how they go from there
but if you're only testing two to three
times a week there's just no freaking
way
that teams are not going to get this
sickness and be overrun by it and and
then we just i don't know are we gonna
have the resources to back it up have
enough players and make it all work i
don't know and again we very much want
there to be football season if we didn't
we would sit back and keep our mouths
shut and let nature take its course
because the manner in which nature is
taking its course right now for me is
very alarming that's why we're speaking
that's why we're putting these ideas out
there we are hoping and praying that the
nfl specifically and society more
generally will do the things necessary
to allow football season to happen and
if you save a hundred thousand lives or
so in the process that's pretty damn
good too so we all need to wake up again
if we were ever awake and maybe stop
paying attention or if we were never
awake we need to pay attention to the
things that need to be done the surgeon
general
a
person who was appointed into the job by
the president said over the weekend
wearing a mask is not an infringement on
your freedom it actually allows you to
better enjoy your freedom because the
more you wear the mask the more likely
you are to go out and do things because
the less likely society is to shut down
again it's not all it's really not that
it's not that hard people it really
isn't that hard to
understand hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports